What should I be taking to ameliorate the effects of radiation therapy?
I am undergoing for a non-small cell lung cancer. I have your radiation
holopathic dropper formula, but the bottle says it's for PET scans and CT scans
So would the holopath work for radiation therapy?
So you're doing radiation therapy through radiation oncologists. They're radiating your lung in this case or whatever they're radiating.
Can you help mitigate some effects of the radiation by using the holopath?
Yes, you can. I'd say yes. I would, I would use if it was me, I would be using the holopath for that as well.
The radiation holopath that we have is for PET scans and CT scans, meaning that it was just tried in that label we were trying to indicate to people that it's the PET scans and CT scans are where you're getting radiation.
So that's where we're trying to block that.
But certainly, if you're doing radiation therapy, you could use that. We also have another holopath from PHP called RADOLIN, RADOLIN or ADYLI or something like that.
So that's another holopath that's kind of multiple different radiation things.
Personally, if you're going to do radiation therapy, I would do both of those.
So, you can call Megan in the store to ask her about the RADOLIN drops. I don't know if I can put that right from PHP as well.